so tell me about some of the ups and
downs that you experienced while running
Bridgewater I'm sure it wasn't all
smooth sailing no no that's the beauty
of it you see
life is a journey right and if you're
not if you're not pushing the limits
you're not going to be at your best so
it's like learning to ski or do
something you're going to fall and
that's part of the process
um so let's see I think that I'll tell
you about one that changed my life so I
formed the company
1975 and then 1980
um I calculated that American Banks had
lent far more money to foreign countries
than those countries were going to be
able to be paid back
and that that was going to cause a debt
crisis a very controversial point of
view and then in August of 1982 Mexico
defaulted on its debts and a number of
other countries defaulted on its debts
and started to produce a crisis
and I thought things were going to get
much worse I thought like you could have
a depression terrible debt crisis and I
couldn't have been more wrong August
1982 when Mexico defaulted that was the
exact bottom in the stock market
and so I lost money for me and I lost
money for clients I uh I was so broke
that I had to borrow four thousand
dollars from my dad to help to take care
of family expenses
um and that was very very painful but it
was one of the best things that hadn't
happened in my life because it gave me
the humility I needed to balance with my
audacity in other words I start to think
how do I know I'm right and what do I do
to handle that and then that approach
started to change because I was I was in
a dilemma I knew that more risk meant
more opportunity and I wanted to have
the best life possible I want to be as
great as possible in terms of all this
but and then risk constrained me and so
it was like sitting on one side of a
jungle and knowing that if I go into the
jungle and cross the jungle I could be
successful
um but I have to get across the step
this jungle how do I deal with risk and
I knew that I didn't want to have an
ordinary life so I had to solve that
puzzle and it changed my Approach so for
example it made me radically open-minded
right okay asking myself how do I know
that I'm right
gave me an open-mindedness I wanted to
find the smartest people I could who
would disagree with me to understand
their thinking to stress test me I want
I knew learned that diversification
could allow me to reduce risk without
reducing return I learned pain plus
reflection equals progress is a big
thing that when you have pain and you
then reflect you learn more about how
reality works and you learn how to
approach it better so my modus operandi
began to change I began to look at
problems like puzzles
and if I could solve the puzzle I would
get a gem and the puzzle is what would I
do differently in the future
and the gem I would get is a principle
of what I would do differently in the
future to make a better outcome and so
my reactions to the pain and the failing
began to change all for that experience
because of that experience